hey there friends today we're going to
learn about air pollution and to start
off we're going back in time to the
small town of donora pennsylvania in
october of 1948.
[Music]
walking into this small industrial town
you can immediately sense that something
is wrong
it's the middle of the day but there's a
thick yellowish smog everywhere
enveloping everything and even blocking
out the sun it's so dark that street
lights are on during the daytime it
stings your eyes and it's hard even
painful to breathe
what we're experiencing is the donora
death fog one of the worst air pollution
disasters in the united states
was an industrial town full of steel
plants and mills which released toxic
emissions such as hydrogen fluoride and
sulfur dioxide when processing steel and
other metals
normally these poisonous gases would
disperse into the atmosphere
but this time there was a temperature
inversion which caused a blanket of warm
air to cover a layer of colder air near
the surface and right over denora
consequently the toxic emissions were
essentially trapped under the warm air
over the course of several days from
october 26th to october 31st these toxic
emissions had accumulated so much that
half of the 14 000 people living in
donora suffered from respiratory
problems and 20 people died
relief only came when the steel mills
were shut down and a rainstorm
alleviated the smog
but following the deadly donora smog the
public began to realize just how
dangerous and life-threatening air
pollution could be and citizens demanded
change donora became a turning point in
u.s history and was the start of the
clean air movement
the air pollution control act of 1955
was the first piece of u.s federal
legislation involving air pollution and
provided funds for research about air
pollution
then in 1963 the clean air act was
passed the first federal legislation to
control air pollution and later expanded
in 1970 which resulted in the creation
of the u.s environmental protection
agency the epa
to develop and enforce regulations to
protect the general public from exposure
to major outdoor air pollutants the
clean air act was expanded in 1977 and
again in 1990 and throughout its nearly
60 year history our air quality has
drastically improved
and pollutants have dropped sharply
since 1990 major air pollutants such as
carbon monoxide nitrogen oxides sulfur
dioxide and volatile organic compounds
have greatly decreased and that's just
since 1990 these four main air balloons
that i highlighted are largely released
as emissions from burning fossil fuels
which comes from driving vehicles and
operating coal-fired power plants and
other industrial facilities
so as we've started to drive more
efficient vehicles and obtain more
energy from clean renewable sources
we've decreased the amount of fossil
fuels that we use and in turn we've
reduced emissions from fossil fuels and
associated air pollutants
but how does the clean air act work
exactly how do we clean the air and
limit emissions of harmful pollutants
cleaner act regulations implemented by
the epa have led to new technologies
that help to limit emissions and remove
pollutants from the air in particular
many of these technologies help to
reduce air pollution from coal burning
power plants and vehicles
each of these pollution control
technologies functions to remove harmful
components out of emissions and release
a less harmful substance
in the last decade or so you've also
probably noticed more and more electric
vehicles on the road
improving the fuel economy of vehicles
and even using battery-powered electric
vehicles can reduce the need to burn as
much gasoline thereby reducing emissions
and giving us cleaner air a good example
is the growing demand for hybrid and
purely electric vehicles here we have a
simplified figure that explains the
sources of energy for different types of
vehicles and their respective emissions
on the left we have conventional
vehicles which rely on fossil fuels such
as gasoline or diesel and when driven
produce lots of emissions like carbon
dioxide and air pollutants
hybrid and plug-in hybrid vehicles are
similar to conventional vehicles and
that they have an internal combustion
engine but they also have an electric
motor which uses energy stored in
batteries these batteries can be charged
by regenerative braking or in the case
of plug-in hybrids just by using a wall
outlet or other charging equipment
in turn because these hybrid cars are
partially fueled by batteries they
produce fewer emissions than a
conventional car
finally vehicles that rely solely on
electricity known as battery electric
vehicles or bevs can use an alternative
electricity source so that there's no
emissions at the source of the
electricity
what else can we do to ensure cleaner
air we can reduce our reliance on fossil
fuels and instead invest in cleaner
renewable resources to generate
electricity such as geothermal wind and
solar
and we can make decisions in our
day-to-day lives to reduce or prevent
air pollution by using less energy and
alternative fuels
for example walking biking or using mass
transportation can reduce the need to
burn fossil fuels and there are plenty
of other ways to reduce our electrical
needs in particular using more energy
efficient appliances
for example think of the led bulb which
uses 75 percent less energy than
incandescent lighting so even switching
out bulbs and the lights around your
house or apartment can make a huge
difference
but there's still many other places out
there like dinora and times folks living
in cities with heavy air pollution
literally can't afford to leave
there's still much work to be done
in dinorah though there's the donora
smog museum which has the tagline clean
air started here the terrible incident
suffered by donors community played a
huge and pivotal role in opening the
eyes of americans the hazards of air
pollution and spur political action
that's carried forth through today and
will continue into the future
let's all take a deep breath and be glad
that we can